hallo mein name ist luca meine lieben
freunde würde dir
nicht in der lage sein türen zu öffnen
oder nur sprinten können
ich habe keine ahnung was ist jetzt mit
einander zu tun hat aber darum geht es
tatsächlich im heutigen video denn wir
spielen wir wieder würdest du eher und
in diesem vergleich hier würde ich ganz
ehrlich er nur springen können
und wenn damit in der mehrheit eine
geile sau auf machen wir jedoch direkt
weiter mit der nächsten
gegenüberstellung und zwar ob wir
unseren zeigefinger oder unseren daumen
verlieren wollen würden zeigefinger wird
es dauern den zeigefinger das sehr gute
sachen zu zeigen und der baum er ist gut
um sachen festzuhalten ich glaube ich
würde er den zeigefinger versorgt
macht ja auch sinn weil wenn einer hier
fehlt greift so aber wenn der fehlt die
solch greifen
würdest du eher zu hause trainieren oder
im fitnessstudio trainieren ich glaube
ich würde das fitnessstudio nehmen ja
kommen wir mit alisa gold mehrheit
während corona extra hier so hand hin
gekauft und eine sitzbank und so unter
abendtrainings dinge aber unterarm habe
ich in coleraine aktivitäten ist
trainiert würdest du eher eine unendlich
große sammlung von filmen haben oder
eine opel um sprachen lernen willst du
lieber ganz viele filme haben oder
videospiele und an der stelle bin ich
ganz ehrlich videospiele mehrheit
videospiele heutzutage fast schon wie
filme sind diese frage hat hier wieder
was mit fingern zu tun und zwar würden
wir lieber einen fehlenden finger haben
oder einen fehlenden c ja in vielen die
deutlich in der mehrheit bin mit ansage
alles richtig habe übrigens auch den
smiley repariert
sonntag hat er wiederum spacken gewesen
alle leute die meinen zweikanal
ammoniten wissen bescheid lupu ging zum
letzten videos mit gollum dienst neuen
würdest du er ein reicher aber dummer
fußballer sein oder ein genie aber ein
schlechter wissenschaftler erreichen
quasi einfach ich würdest du er ein
spion sein oder ein superheld definitiv
superheld
er gibt ja auch viel mehr sind dann hast
du ja logischerweise eben hier super
kraft und beispielen da bist einfach nur
gut im leise sein kenne den moment
deines eigenen todes oder kenne den
moment des todes der person du am
meisten liebt
das sind teilweise sehr krass die
befragen aber ich bin ganz ehrlich ich
würde lieber wissen wollen eine andere
person
stirbt anstatt ich
ja dass immer nicht immer unordentliches
ungepflegtes haar haben oder immer
flecken auf seiner kleidung haben ich
glaube eher oberes genau wie noch in der
mehrheit weil ich das ehemals ab
ich habe ja nie irgendwie
ordnung hier in meiner friese würdest du
er sofort einen vierjährigen
uni-abschluss haben und das ganze wissen
inklusive oder 100.000 dollar button
nein definitiv das obere
wenn ich das habe vier jahre
uni-abschluss plus das ganze wissen ob
ich mir selber drei jahre steht das
ganze wissen dass ich schon weg dann
könnte man aber logischerweise deutlich
mehr verdienen als wenn ich jetzt
einfach hunderttausend dollar bar haben
würde das wäre bei mir hat ein
schlechter dienstag war bist du ja
extrem paranoid sein oder naiv sein okay
extrem paranoid heißt ich habe vor allem
möglichen sollt angst oder naiv also ich
bin leichtgläubig und schnell zu
überstimmen therapie bisschen dümmlich
dann bin ich eher naiv
dieses extrem mag es auch noch mal krass
weil wenn man extrem paranoid ist der
richtige angst zustände wahrscheinlich
würdest du er alle schlechten fahrer auf
der straße los werden also quasi einfach
peyton oder nie mehr in geschäften und
restaurants schlange stehen müssen es
sind wieder zwei dinge die man überhaupt
nicht miteinander vergleichen kann was
haben schlechte autofahrer auf der
straße dann plötzlich weg wären damit zu
tun dass plötzlich leute die in der
schlange vor mir stehen weg sind aber
gut ich würde trotzdem zweiteres nehmen
und auch hier eine mehrheit
ich bin jetzt verletzt sind so wenig
autos sind schlechte fahrer auf der
straße wirklich legal adviser seitdem
ich wieder in köln nicht zu fuß und ja
die hypo kommt bald würdest du er keine
finger haben oder keine ohren die frage
ist wenn ich keine ohren habe dann
könnte ich ja dementsprechend auch
nichts hören ich kenne finger habe
könnte ich nichts greifen aber da könnte
ich mir ja irgendwie amputierte dinger
weil wenn man keine ohren hat dann
nichts hören kann es ist wieder
schwierig also ich würde eher kleine
finger haben komma da steht keine ohren
also redet auch wenn ich trotzdem hören
könnte dann will ich auch dass neben
niemals hausaufgaben haben oder niemals
irgendwelche prüfungen haben es sind
echt schwierige sachen hier mittlerweile
also hausaufgaben hat man ja fast
täglich fünf von sieben tagen in der
woche muss man hausaufgaben machen oder
ich
keinen dieser tage ist immer irgendwie
abgeschrieben habe vom unterricht wurde
ich habe nie irgendwelche prüfungen aber
ich bin ganz ehrlich ich mache lieber
mein leben lang hausaufgaben während der
schulzeit mäßig das leben dann macht es
ähnlich als dass ich dann irgendwie vor
den prüfungen irgendwie nächtelang durch
brocken wenn also niemals prüfungen auch
ihre mehrheit
ich freue mich über dinge die recht
einfach bardal sind möchte das niemanden
smiley repariert haben
das ist so stark also ich einfach für
den rest deines lebens alleinsein oder
immer von nervigen menschen umgeben sein
also entweder komplett allein oder
nervige menschen die sache ist vom klum
geht es neben schon nämlich 23
minderheit
hast denn raab minimum grüßt er immer
kalt duschen oder immer eine stunde
weniger schlafen als du brauchst um
vollständig ausgeruht zu sein beides ist
bei mir der fall ich habe den letzten
zwei wochen keine einzige nacht mehr als
acht stunden geschlafen also immer mal
so drei stunden dann sechs stunden
wieder vier stunden wieder sieben
stunden wieder vier stunden dann wieder
fünf stunden immer so um den dreh und
mit kalt duschen ich bin dann kalt
duscht sich komplett kalte rasieren
halbem herzen faktor war mit raus trat
ausser dusche morgens aber zumindest
jetzt nicht sondern so heiß oder so weil
das macht mich nicht wach von daher kalt
duschen
mein laufe sehen wie vor beide würdest
du er doppelt so große arme haben oder
doppelt so große beine haben kann man
die sache ist wirklich also mein bizeps
ich bin ganz zufrieden mit oder sogar
will ich jetzt nicht irgendwie groß
verändern wollen aber meine beine
neben doppelt so große beide ich finde
der mehrheit das hätte ich nicht gedacht
wenn viele sagen aber so baumann den
beiden habe ich speck und da will ich
abnehmen blabla medica ich habe einfach
so zahnstocher dann würdest du an einem
größeren zimmer für mehr miete leben
oder in einem kleineren zimmer für
weniger miete also die frage ist hier
einfach wie viel geld ist mir meine
wohnung und meine wohnsituation generell
wert dann würde ich eher wirklich in
einem größeren zimmer für mehr miete
leben und ich bin in der minderheit
mir persönlich ist es halt extrem
wichtig wie der ort ist in dem ich lebe
das wichtigste ist darüber im kopf wie
man ganz finanziell spricht kümmert euch
erst darum dass ihr das ganze geld
beiseite legt im monat was er verdient
für miete oder vielleicht wenn ihr
irgendwie richtig gut verdient dann
irgend eine immobilie kaufen blabla
bevor man sich in anderen schwachsinn
schon ein ganz schönes sprichwort hier
zum video alle meine lieben freunde denn
an der stelle würde ich sagen halt ja
wie gesagt dass wir jetzt auch beenden
von daher wenn es euch gefallen hat das
kann einen daumen hoch unter dem video
hier da abonniert main kanal und der
krebs verständlich auf die glocke um
weitere videos nicht verpassen ich bin
jetzt bei power band gestoßen in köln
ich muss mich noch ein bisschen an die
an die situation gewöhnen aber bald
kommt auf jeden fall ihm tue ich
bekommen dazu gerade aktuell sehr viele
nachrichten weil mein hund uhr hamburg
video an den trends war und gut
abgegangen ist bei euch und das kann
auch echt extrem gut an wir sind gerade
noch dabei ist ein bisschen elektro
krams zu machen die terrasse ist doch
gar nicht gemacht was passiert das im
september
ich weiß nicht ob ich die route vorher
schon machen oder ist man die terrasse
fertig ist aber nervt mich nicht damit
geht raus spielen hier regnet aber nimmt
ein regenschirm it sonst einfach song
live act von mir wenn es regnet kann man
regenschirm mitnehmen dann wird man
nicht los